is let's take you back to washington and
listen to the speaker of the us house of
representatives
nancy pelosi
good evening everyone it is my honor to
be here with members of the house
leadership
leader hoyer with qyburn
assistant speaker katherine clark also
with our managers
uh for the impeachment our lead manager
jamie raskin
diana degette david sussolini joaquin
castro
eric swalwell
madeline dean and joe the goose i think
ted lou and stacy pascal are in here
telecom
electronically one way or another but
we're very proud
that they have accepted the
responsibility
a responsibility we do not think one
week ago
we would have today in a bipartisan way
the house
demonstrated that no one is above the
law
not even the president of the united
states
that donald trump is a clear and present
danger to our country
and that once again we honored our oath
of office
to protect and defend the constitution
of the united states so help us god
and now i sadly
and with her heart broken over what this
means to our country
of a president who would cite
insurrection
will sign the engrossment of the article
of impeachment
so
thank you speaker he disappointed us
[Music]
how long do you think